this is a normal British terraced house
it was built around the turn of the 20th
century out of bricks mortar and a lot
of manual labour kitchen living room and
a set of stairs in the middle that lead
up to two bedrooms and a bathroom and
although the exact details might be
different about one in five houses in
Britain look roughly like this all built
in a row trouble is houses like this
weren't built to save energy or to keep
the heating on a cold winter's day
energy efficiency wasn't really a thing
a century ago and while there are all
sorts of plans to modernize in retrofit
houses how do you know which plans will
work how do you do a controlled
experiment when every house is different
and the weather constantly changes it'd
be great if you could just you know tell
the Sun what to do we're in the salt for
the energy house which is the only whole
building in a climate control chamber
the idea really was to take a Victorian
house and look at different ways that we
could make it more energy-efficient when
you test something on its own like a
boiler you know you sit in a lab and you
test it and it will be X percent
efficient when you actually put that in
a whole house or a whole system it then
interacts with all sorts of other things
like the fabric the radiators the
controls so understanding how things fit
together as a whole house is really
really important this isn't some closest
approximation of an old terraced house
made with modern techniques this was a
genuine and a terrace house from Alba
Manchester it was taken apart and then
rebuilt piece by piece here an
environmental test chamber at the
University of Salford we had to get a
bricklayer the bricklayers like 70 years
old because actually the way that the
bricks were laid in Victorian times
nobody does it like that anymore
he said he'd not laid bricks like that
since he was a trainee we've gone oh I
would say hundreds of sensors every
single appliance is monitored
individually what we can do here is also
simulate human activity we have
actuators so that like robotic arms
which will replicate the opening closing
of doors fridges windows we can turn
appliances on and off here we control
the weather we have a
space next door with a big water tank
and there are layers of piping that run
round that will push rain onto the side
of the building because rain never falls
down I always come sideways and then we
also have a snow machine and we also
have wind machines and we have a
lighting system so that's a just radiant
heating lamps connected to a theater
lighting control system so the Sun can
pass around the building all of those
things make huge difference the way a
building performs the first really big
test we did which was a whole house
retrofits we attached wall insulation we
improved the doors and the windows and
we improved the floor and we reduced the
heating energy by more than 60% there's
always a trade-off with experiments like
this yes heating and cooling a large
building that is inside another building
it's not massively energy efficient of
itself but compared to other industrial
processes it's not that bad and if
spending a little energy here saves a
lot elsewhere well that's probably worth
it thank you very much to everyone at
the energy house and the University of
Salford School of built environment you
can see their YouTube channel here or
pull down the description for more about
them and about the house